Alicia Frame: Thank
you all for coming.
I'm Alicia Frame, and I'm
joined by Omkar More.
And we are here to tell
you about fine-tuning
and reinforcement learning.
I am the Product Lead
for Model Customization,
Omkar is my engineering
counterpart,
and what we're going to tell you
about today is how you
can deploy, observe,
and learn from your production
agents to get better, smarter,
cheaper, and faster models.
One thing, just to call
out before I get started, is,
it's a little noisy in here.
If you're having trouble
hearing, there are headsets
in the back that you can get
so that you can kind of cut
through the background noise,
but I will try to be super
loud so you can hear me.
And with that,
let's get started.
So what are we going
to cover today?
We're going to start with the
basics, five minutes of slides,
and we're going to talk
about what is fine-tuning,
why fine-tune, and what
does this have to do
with production agents?
From there, we're going to
get started with the demos.
The first demo we're going
to show you is how you can use
a technique called distillation
to create cheaper
and faster agents.
Next, we're going
to deal with, what
if your teacher
isn't smart enough?
How can we use
reinforcement learning
to learn from our mistakes?
After that, one level
harder, we're going to talk
about interactive reinforcement
learning, and you're all going
to get a preview of our new,
low-level training API.
Think of it as
PyTorch as a service.
You get access to the
low-level training primitives,
we manage the compute.
we build better models for you.
And then, after
you've had a little bit
of a panic attack of, "Wow,
that was a lot of content",
we're going to end with
coding agents for fine-tuning
and show you how you can
use our fine-tuning skill
to really use natural language
to describe your goals
and create better
models in minutes.
And with that,
let's get started.
So, before we dive
in, I want to situate you
in the bigger picture.
We're part of the
Microsoft Foundry team,
and Foundry gives you
your agent platform.
The foundation is models.
There are over 11,000
models in Foundry,
and these models power
our agent runtime,
let you deploy and
host your agents,
observe them, give them tools.
And once you've got those
agents, we want them
to be better and smarter.
So we offer tooling
to evaluate them,
know if they're doing
what you want them to do,
and optimize them, improve
their performance based
on what you've observed.
This talk is really
going to be focusing
on the Evaluate
and Optimize box.
But I want to motivate this talk
and explain why we're here.
We've been working on
fine-tuning for a while,
and I feel like people are
finally starting to listen
to, "there is a reason
to customize models."
And what we're seeing now
is agents have taken off.
Agents helped us make
this slide deck.
Agents helped us make this demo.
A third of enterprise software
apps say they're going
to embed agentic AI
within two years.
I think that's wrong.
I think the number is
higher and sooner.
Half of teams already have some
kind of production agent today.
The problem: agents consume 20
to 30 times more tokens per turn
than an old-fashioned
chat interaction.
And so, all of a sudden, we have
way more models being deployed
for way more use cases,
consuming way more tokens.
And all of a sudden,
we've broken the bank,
you've run out of tokens, your
credit card is maxed out.
What do we do?
And so, if agents are
token-consuming machines,
fine-tuning lets you
create a reliable agent
without breaking the bank.
And so, what does
fine-tuning do?
When you customize a model,
you can create a cheaper,
faster, smarter model.
So, historically, I think when
people think about fine-tuning,
they think about
improving model quality.
Two years ago, a lot
of people said, "Wow,
I need to fine-tune
GPT-3.5 Turbo
to teach it about my domain."
Today, when we talk
about improving quality,
especially in the
context of agents,
it's really about calling the
right tool at the right time
with the right inputs.
Improving quality is
really about baking
in those instructions from
your prompt into the weights
of the model itself, and
that is super important.
But it's not the full story.
What we're seeing
more and more of --
and you saw this probably
in sessions where we talked
about Harvey or UiPath,
many companies are fine-tuning
smaller, cheaper, faster models
to power their production
agents for their use cases
with the same quality
as a frontier model
at a fraction of the price.
So the targets of fine-tuning
are often 10 to 30 times cheaper
than a frontier model.
So we're talking about
replacing GPT-5.4 with 4.1 nano
or a Qwen model,
something much cheaper.
And so when you're looking at
something 30 times cheaper,
even if it's consuming
30 times the tokens,
your budget still balances.
The other thing we worry
about with agents is they're
chatty, but we're impatient.
The big frontier
models can be slow.
We've all sat there and
watched Claude churn,
and you're like, "I'm bored.
I'm bored. Come on."
Small models
stream tokens faster.
So your agentic workflows, once
you've got that smaller model,
it responds more quickly.
So you really now have kind
of the perfect solution.
You've got a model that knows
what tools to call and how
to behave, and it's
cheaper, and it's faster.
And so, because of this, we're
seeing a lot more traction
for fine-tuning
and customization.
When we talk about optimization,
it's really a journey.
So, in Foundry, you often
start from, "I built my agent.
I've got to get
the prompt right.
Can I give it instructions
to make it do what I want?"
Step two is, "Okay.
I need to add context
management to my agent runtime.
I'm going to give it data,
grounding, and memory.
And then, I can give it
tools so it can take actions
and call external things."
And then, at all this
time, I'm evaluating it.
I'm checking if it's
doing what I want.
I'm checking how
it's performing.
Once we've got that, though, now
it becomes time to optimize.
"Is my model doing
the wrong stuff?
Is it too expensive?
Is it too slow?"
And that's where
fine-tuning comes in.
And so, this talk today
is really going to focus
on this right-hand side of
this optimization curve.
And I already said, fine-tuning
is becoming more popular
as we see the rise of agents,
and we're seeing this in
the developer world.
About half of developers
say that they want
to replace their out-of-the-box
models with fine-tuning.
Three years ago, people
-- maybe four years ago,
people were like, "I'm going to
build my own foundation model."
And then, we kind of moved on,
and everyone said,
"Ah, you know what?
Out-of-the-box
models are amazing.
I'm good. I don't
need to do this."
Now, people are starting to
look at their balance sheets
or their CSAT, and they're
saying, "Actually,
maybe fine-tuning is for me."
And this really gets back
to the cost compounding
in the agency loop.
And it ends up being about
quality, latency, and cost,
all driving people
towards this decision.
And now, I've said the word
"fine-tuning" like 30 times,
and some of you, probably anyone
who is not a data scientist,
is like, "What is fine-tuning?"
So I got to this a little late,
but fine-tuning is really
just your cheat code
to building a foundation model.
So if we go back to, "Where
do these models come from?",
the way you build a
foundation model is you start
with pre-training.
You have a massive amount
of unlabeled data,
and you start off by figuring
out next token prediction.
So,"I've got one word;
what's the next
most likely word?"
Once you've got that, you
often use instruction tuning,
where you give prompt-response
data, task-specific data,
to teach the model
how to respond.
And then, the final step is
going to be alignment tuning,
where you give the model human
preference data, reward models,
to really steer how you
want it to respond.
You put these three
steps together,
you get your frontier model.
Fine-tuning lets you kind
of skip the most expensive,
hardest, complicated part.
You pick up your generic,
off-the-shelf model that's
pretty good, and then
you get to choose,
"Do I want to do
supervised fine-tuning?",
so teach it to behave in a
certain way, give it data
to copy and learn from,
"Or do I want to align it?
Or do I want to do both?"
And so, you kind of
get a head start
in the customization
journey, add your data,
and create your own IP.
And so, with that, we've kind
of given you the crash course
in fine-tuning, and we're going
to get to the first demo,
which is, I'm sure, what
you all care about.
And so, point one is we're going
to do "cheaper and faster".
So a really common technique in
the world of model customization
and fine-tuning is distillation.
And this is where you take a
large, smart model like GPT-5.5,
and you capture its traffic and
use that as your training data.
What we're going to show
you is how you take traces
from your production agent,
filter and curate them,
create a training set, and from
that, generate your small,
fine-tuned model
that is just as good
as your high-quality
frontier model.
So, with that, we're going
to switch to the demo.
Omkar More: All right.
So throughout this demo and
throughout the talk today,
we're going to see -- we're
going to show you a variety
of techniques for post-training
with the intention of making all
of your models faster,
cheaper, and smarter.
So across all of these demos,
we're going to concentrate
on a single customer scenario.
This customer scenario is
about building a
customer service agent
for a retail scenario.
So let's say you
have a retailer,
and you have a customer service
agent that processes refunds.
So a customer calls in, asks for
a refund for a particular item.
The agent has to go ahead
and decide whether the
request was valid.
It has to decide whether
the item could be returned.
It also has to decide whether
the item should be replaced
or refunded.
So these are complex scenarios
that the agent has to navigate.
The agent can look at the
order details via tool.
It could also go and look
at the fulfillment status.
It could go and look
at the policy details
and then process the payments.
But what if it gets it wrong?
If it gets it wrong,
it could lead
to the retailer losing
a lot of money.
And as you know --
Alicia Frame: Or a
lot of customers.
Omkar More: Or a lot of
customers, and online returns is
about $900 billion of
business in the US last year.
So it's very critical for us
to get this scenario right.
So with that setup,
let's go ahead and look
at how we can do distillation
from a larger model
like a 5.4 model to a smaller
4.1 or 4.1 mini model and see
if we can get the models to
be faster and cheaper, okay?
Alicia Frame: Okay.
Omkar More: All right.
So I have, over here
-- let's go over to.
All right.
So let's go to our agents.
Okay.
Alicia Frame: And so, as
you're pulling this up,
for folks who haven't used it
before, this is our Foundry UI.
This is a really simple,
no-code way to build agents,
fine-tune models, but this is
also all possible from code.
Omkar More: Absolutely.
So, to start with, I have
built a hosted agent.
So Foundry allows you to use
any platform that you want,
any agent platform
like Semantic Kernel,
if you want to use LangGraph,
and host your agents on Foundry.
So I have done that over here.
This is an agent that is using
GPT-5.4 as its base model.
And let's try it out
with an example.
Not this one.
Maybe this one.
All right.
So the customer is asking
to return a yoga mat,
which they have not used, and
see if we can process a refund.
Foundry agents allow --
Foundry-hosted agents allow you
to actually capture all the
traces so that you can use
that to evaluate and further
use it to fine-tune as well.
So, as you can see, the
request has been resolved,
and you can look at the traces
to see what exactly happened
during the entire process.
Alicia Frame: So can
you show us the tools
that your agent is
calling in here?
Omkar More: Absolutely.
So here's what has happened.
So, if you see, the user view
shows you what the request was
and what the final outcome was.
But the trajectories
actually show you
which of our tools were invoked.
In this case, the "get
order details" was invoked.
After that, we had the
"fulfillment status" invoked,
and then the "check
resolution policy",
and then the final
outcome was resulted.
So this is really rich
data that you can use
to evaluate your models and
also use it to improve them.
So, going back, let's go
ahead and look at the
"Traces" tab in hosted agents.
You'll see that this
agent has been working
for the last few days,
and we have about --
I think, about a thousand-odd
traces that have been captured.
And we'll use these to actually
go ahead and evaluate the model.
Now, the first step to
think about this is,
"Can I just replace my large
model with a smaller model
and see how it performs?"
So let's go ahead and build
up an evaluation scenario
and see how they stack
up in the first place before we
do any fine-tuning whatsoever.
Alicia Frame: So, really,
you're basically showing
us that we're not lying.
We're going to start
with no fine-tuning,
just smaller and cheaper.
Let's see how well it works out.
Omkar More: All right.
And this I'm going to
do with the SDK.
So let's go ahead
and start that up.
So a few things to talk
about over here is --
let me just start
off this and then --
Alicia Frame: So are you
loading up all of your evals
to be able to check how
well the models perform?
Omkar More: Yes.
So, now, Foundry allows you
to have different graders.
So it allows
out-of-the-box graders
like task resolution,
intent resolution.
So these are LLM-based graders
that can look at the trajectory
and tell what the intent was,
and was it actually done or not.
So you could use that.
Or you could get more control
by writing your own graders.
And we allow you to write
graders backed by an LLM
or using pure
Python code itself.
So, in this case, I have written
a Python grader, which allows me
to grade the responses
on three fronts:
whether the decision was right --
in case the refund was supposed
to be done or was it rejected.
So I give 50% weightage to that.
How accurate was it,
from the dollar amount.
So if it was a $50 item,
was I refunding $500?
So that kind of thing.
And then it also grades
about 20% weight
for the format itself,
because this is important,
because your downstreams are
dependent upon how the model
format is given.
Alicia Frame: And really,
without this, we have no way
of knowing, one, if the
agent works or not, but two,
whether fine-tuning makes
anything better or worse.
So this is really the
most foundational step.
Omkar More: Yes.
And then, I build an
evaluation, which has all
of these three graders and
then submit an eval run
for the base models.
And let's go ahead
and have a look
at the evaluations themselves.
Alicia Frame: And so,
whenever you're generating
something from the SDK,
it's automatically
registered in the UI.
So if you want a beautiful
view of your eval,
you can just click
over here and see it.
Omkar More: Yeah.
So, as you can see, the o4-mini
and GPT-5.4 do reasonably
okay, 65% quality score.
But the smaller models,
which is 4.1-mini
and nano, perform really poorly.
And you don't want to
replace them as-is just
to save cost and latency.
So, what do we do?
Alicia Frame: Cry?
Omkar More: Well,
Foundry to the rescue.
You can actually use the traces
that we have just captured
to fine-tune a smaller model
and see how it performs now.
And they make it so simple
that you can actually do it
through the UI directly.
So let me go ahead and
show you just that.
So go to "Retail."
This is my agent.
We'll go back to the traces
that we saw earlier.
And then, click on the
"Create Dataset" button.
This allows you to convert
your traces from raw traces
into datasets that you
can use for evaluation,
for reinforcement fine-tuning,
or for supervised fine-tuning.
So it does a little bit
smarter things here.
It removes all the duplicates.
Your trajectories might have
non-interesting conversations
that can be taken off.
It will redact some of
the PII information
as well before it
uses it for training.
So I'm going to go and try
to do supervised
fine-tuning over here.
You will see that we
have -- let me see.
Okay. Hold on.
All right.
So, as you can see, I have
about 1,400 traces here.
Supervised fine-tuning -- and
we suggest you at least have
about a thousand samples.
When you go to "Reinforcement
Fine-Tuning," you will see
that we can do a lot more with
the smaller dataset as well.
So I'm going to use a thousand
samples for here and then click
on "Start Fine-Tuning" to
start the wizard right here.
Let's go ahead and select
maybe GPT-4.1 mini or nano.
You'll see a few options
that you can select while you
kick off a SFT run as well.
So, for instance, the training
type gives you different SKUs
that you can use to govern
data residency and your cost.
My favorite over here is
the developer preview,
which allows you to do
training at half of the cost
of a standard-tier job.
Alicia Frame: So
if you're worried
about fine-tuning
being expensive,
developer tier, 50% off.
Omkar More: Yes.
It runs on our low-priority VMs,
so it could take
a little longer,
but for developers,
it's pretty good.
We also introduced at Build
today the data zone SKU
that allows you to have
residency guarantees in US.
So I'm going to use
just the standard for now.
Also, you'll see that the
datasets are already preloaded
from the -- converted from
the traces into here,
so you don't need to go
ahead and add any datasets.
Then, you can click on over here
to have it
automatically deployed
to a model after job completion.
We'll skip that for now.
And you'll see that we
have a few hyperparameters
that you can tweak.
And for higher and more control,
you might need more
hyperparameters.
We'll show in the next few demos
how you can get more control
onto your fine-tuning process.
Alicia Frame: But here is
really just easy mode, right?
Omkar More: Yes.
So you can just go ahead and
click just a few clicks,
and then your training is started.
Let's go ahead and open up a
run that is already completed.
So this is a distillation
run that we did earlier,
and you can go ahead on the
"Monitor" tab to see the scores.
You'll see there that
the loss is reducing,
accuracy is increasing,
everything looking good.
You can see that we --
not just the final model,
you'll also get checkpoints
for interesting cases wherein
the reward might have
increased before the last step.
You can use that to deploy
and have a model as well.
Or if you think that you need
to further fine-tune this
with more data, you can
use continuous fine-tuning
and go ahead and
submit another run.
In this case, the run
looks pretty good.
I have actually gone ahead
and deployed this earlier.
I have created an agent on top
of it and ran the evaluation,
just in the interest of time.
And we can go ahead and look at
that evaluation run right now
to see how it stacks up.
All right.
And let's go ahead and
sort it by retail order.
Okay. So, as you can see,
we have a new winner.
So GPT-4.1 mini fine-tuned
actually outperforms o4-mini
and 5.4 as well,
which is amazing.
Now, you have --
your agents can --
Alicia Frame:
Fraction of the cost.
Omkar More: Fraction
of the cost.
Your agents are
faster and cheaper.
Alicia Frame: And I guess
maybe a little smarter.
Omkar More: And slightly
more performant as well.
Alicia Frame: And the
other thing I want to call
out is you did include those
default graders, right?
Omkar More: Yes.
Absolutely.
Alicia Frame: The intent
resolution, task completion.
And what we can see there is,
we're not trying to fine-tune
to improve those, but our
fine-tuning hasn't eroded the
base model's capabilities.
So one fear with fine-tuning is,
maybe I made it better at this,
but worse at other stuff.
But we have those
guardrails in place
to make sure that didn't happen.
So that was awesome.
Omkar More: Thank you.
Alicia Frame: So what is
our current leaderboard?
Seventy-four percent.
That's an improvement.
We've brought down our budget.
We're still kind of holding with
that frontier model standard.
But $900 billion, 74% of
that, we're still losing
over $100 billion with
spurious refunds.
So what do we need to do?
Sometimes your teacher
isn't smart enough.
So with distillation,
what we just showed you,
where you have your teacher
model, frontier class,
generate a bunch of data,
fine-tune a small model using
supervised fine-tuning.
With those techniques,
super easy to do,
but you're really never going to
get smarter than your teacher.
The source of the training data,
the mark you're trying to hit,
is the teacher performance.
But for us, if we
look at this and say,
"74% is really not good
enough for our business;
we need a new technique."
And that's where reinforcement
learning comes in.
And so, in this scenario,
what you're doing is
the model itself learns
from its own mistakes.
So we define a grader, and
so all the work we put
into evaluating the baseline,
evaluating our fine-tuned
models, comes in handy.
We use that same grader to
score the model's own responses
and learn from those scores.
So your model generates sample
results, you score them,
you learn from the
best-performing results,
and the model, over time, learns
how to reason, in this case,
through multiple different
tool calls that it has
to chain and put together.
The one caveat, though, for
reinforcement learning is, most
of the time, it needs to
be a verifiable task.
So what you're doing is you're
grading if the response is good
or not and learning
from that signal.
If you can't grade it,
you can't learn from it.
But the good news is
refunds are gradable.
You can look at
it and say, "Yes,
you should have refunded that,"
or, "No, that was terrible."
And so, this is a
perfect scenario
where we can score whether
it's getting better or worse.
So, next demo,
reinforcement learning,
learning from the
agent's mistakes.
And so, before we dive
into the tech again,
I'm going to just spend 30
seconds explaining kind
of what's happening
under the hood.
So, with reinforcement
learning, you send your prompt
to the model, and the model
generates multiple samples.
These are called rollouts.
And so, here, the model
has generated three
possible samples.
The grader you defined
scores those samples.
And the quality of your
grader is basically going
to determine whether
this works or not.
If there's no signal, if
your grader is just like,
"Everything is wrong", or
"Everything is right",
there's nowhere to go.
So you need a grader that, one,
grades the outcome you want,
and two, leaves room
for improvement.
So you need an initial
signal, and then you need
to iterate from there.
Once you've got your quality
score from your grader,
that information is
fed into your trainer.
You reinforce the correct
answers, you learn from them,
and the model learns to
reason about a new domain.
And if that sounds a little
complicated, Omkar is going
to show you how simple
it is to do in our UI.
Omkar More: Thank you, Alicia.
So let's go ahead and look at
reinforcement fine-tuning.
So we saw in the previous
demo, we took a teacher model.
The teacher model had the entire
trajectories spelled out.
So what tools were
supposed to be called,
what were the responses?
All of this was spelled out, and
that was the training dataset
that was used for fine-tuning.
Supervised fine-tuning is
like learning by seeing
or copying what a
smarter person is doing.
But in reinforcement
fine-tuning,
what we do is we don't give
the exact trajectories
or prescription of "These are the
tools that need to be called."
Instead, we give the ability
for the training process itself
to invoke these tools on the
fly and then take the responses
of those tools and use that
to grade against the grader
that we wrote in the
evaluation flow,
and see which of these responses
are giving better results,
and then continuously try
to find out or reason about it
to make better decisions.
Alicia Frame: So you're
giving the models the tools
to answer the questions, and the
model figures it out on its own.
Omkar More: Exactly.
So now let's go ahead and see
how you can do this in Foundry.
So I'm here with the SDK.
So let's go step-by-step.
So we're going to have
the configuration done.
And one thing that you want
to note over here is, look
at the training and
the validation data.
This data is, again, coming
from the traces itself.
But the training data right now
doesn't have the entire tool
call history.
It only has the actual message
that the user had asked.
And then, it has some ground
truth that will be used
by the grader to grade this.
So for instance,
you will have the final score
that has to be refunded, but
it won't have which tools
to be called to
get to that thing.
It wouldn't have the message
body itself that needs
to be returned, and so on.
So we do this, we upload it to
Foundry, and then let's go ahead
and look at the most important
part, which is the RFT grader.
So you can use the
evaluation grader
that we already wrote itself,
or you could tweak it as well.
So, in this case, I have added
some coverage to tools itself,
which exact tools
are getting called.
So, for instance, I don't
want to have a high score
for a response where the "get
orders" is not even invoked.
So, in those cases,
I can have control
over how I want the
grader to behave.
Alicia Frame: And this
is really important
for avoiding things
like reward hacking.
So a failure mode
when we were working
on putting this together was,
the model would get things wrong
and just learn, "I will
never call a tool",
because it was getting penalized
for calling the wrong tool.
Omkar More: Yes, and
you'll see that.
Yeah.
And when we'll see
the run itself,
you will see how you can avoid
this by looking at our telemetry
and the metrics
that will tell you
when such a thing does happen.
All right.
So now, we said we need to
give access to the tools
to the training run itself.
How do you do that?
So, in this case, I have
hosted all of these tools
on a function app, and these
function apps can be invoked.
These are real tool
calls that can be made.
It has some of this information.
It's like your RL harness or
RL environment, so to say.
You could also use MCP servers
or anywhere else you
have your tools hosted.
And let's go ahead
and kick off a run.
And let's go ahead and look
at this run through Foundry
to see what were
the hyperparameters
and how an earlier
run has performed.
Okay. This is queued.
So here's a completed run.
So you get a few
more things here.
So you get access to a
few more hyperparameters
that are specific to
reinforcement fine-tuning,
especially to a reasoning
model like o4-mini.
You get to choose what is the
reasoning effort the model has
to put in.
You can set it to
low, medium, or high.
This tells you how much chain
of thought the model has to do
so that it can come
to the right answer.
And this has implications
on what your token cost
is going to be as well.
Next up, you can also change
the number of epochs,
evaluation interval,
and things thereabout.
You will see this is how I
have configured the tools
to be called to
the function app.
Alicia Frame: And so this
really tells the training run,
"These are the
tools you can use."
Omkar More: Yes.
This is the real training run.
When the training is happening,
the tools are getting invoked,
and then those results are
what is getting used rather
than just copying like
in supervised fine-tuning.
Let's go ahead and look
at the "Monitor" tab
to see what the
results look like.
So the primary metric that you
want to look at is rewards.
Are the rewards
increasing over time,
and are the rewards increasing
for your validation
set over time?
As you can see, that looks good.
Both the train and validation
rewards are increasing.
The other interesting thing
to notice here is the
reasoning token mean per step.
You can see that the model
was trying to spend a lot
of reasoning effort early
on in the training process,
but as it goes on, the
reasoning effort comes down.
So this, again, has
implications in terms
of how much tokens will be
used by your fine-tuned model,
because now the final checkpoint
will use a lot less reasoning
than the base model itself.
Alicia Frame: And so, early on,
it's just calling a whole
bunch of different tools,
trying to figure it out.
Omkar More: And the other
thing you would look
at is the number of
tool calls per rollout.
So, in case it determined
that, "Hey, I don't want to --"
or penalized tool calling itself
and then stop calling
tools altogether,
you will notice a dip over
here and then say that, "Hey,
there's something wrong with
this run," and you would want
to iterate on top of your
grader to tweak these things.
Okay. So, with that done,
let's go ahead and look
at the evaluations on how
this model fares amongst
our leaderboard.
So we have done
the distillation.
We have looked at the RFT evals.
Let's go and check it out.
So, again, we have a new winner.
We have o4-mini
coming up at 84%.
Yeah. So that's a huge bump up
from where it was at 75 -- 73%.
And the intent resolution
and task completion
are also increasing
or maybe staying stable.
So this is how you can use --
the more effort that you put in,
the better what you get.
So, for instance, reinforcement
learning can be a bit
of an effort to get it right,
making sure that your
model graders are correct,
the runs can take
a little longer,
but the outcome is
also substantial.
Alicia Frame: And importantly,
we're still keeping true to that
better, cheaper, faster, right?
Because o4-mini is
still a smaller model
than 5.4, which is our teacher.
Omkar More: Yeah, it's
substantially cheaper than 5.4.
Alicia Frame: So going back
to, if you saw in the keynote,
that hill climbing narrative,
we're kind of on our
way up the hill.
And before we dive
back into more demos,
I do like to take one moment to
share some real-world use cases.
This is not just demo-ware.
This is not just us
making up a new use
for some stuff we think is cool.
We have customers using
this in production.
So, Decagon AI, they build,
actually, customer support agent
as a service.
They used distillation and
fine-tuning on Foundry
to power their service,
switching to smaller,
cheaper, faster models.
Discovery Bank used
distillation and fine-tuning
to create a smaller,
faster, lower-latency model
to power their banking app.
This was a scenario where
customers were texting the app
and getting a response, and
they went from six seconds
down to one and a half seconds.
And for customer
satisfaction, that's huge.
And Docusign is probably one of
our biggest token customers.
They were able to distill and
see a 50% reduction in cost
for AI document processing.
So distillation, fine-tuning,
reinforcement learning,
are really critical tools
in the toolbox for making
agents economically viable
and delightful to use.
So we're still only at 84%.
Omkar More: Yep.
Alicia Frame: That's still,
maybe, $90 billion lost.
So what if we need more control?
Mostly what we've shown you
so far was super simple,
UI-based, high-level APIs.
Some of you, if anyone here is a
data scientist, an AI scientist,
are like, "Uh-uh, I want
to define my own
rollout environment.
I want to define
my own algorithm.
I want full control over
the hyperparameters."
And if that is you, get excited.
We're going to give
you a sneak peek
of our new,
interactive training API.
Before we show you what it
is, it's helpful to just kind
of compare and contrast how the
two different services work.
So everything we've shown you
so far is, really,
managed fine-tuning.
You are the user.
You pick your model.
You pick your
technique: SFT, RFT.
You provide your data, and
you submit it to the service.
And the service does the
rollouts, grades the responses,
does the loss computation,
updates the weights,
and iterates as a closed
loop before it returns
a checkpoint.
You can't mess with
what's happening
in that service boundary.
Our new training API actually
gives you much more control.
You, as the practitioner, set
up the config, the recipe.
You invoke the rollout engine.
You compute the loss.
You update the weights.
And then look, we're back
outside that service boundary,
so you update the grader itself.
And the big difference here
is you're controlling the
algorithm, the training
primitives, every aspect
of the fine-tuning job, except
the GPU infrastructure.
So if anyone here has used
Pearl or attempted
to use Pearl and failed,
we're abstracting away all
the pain of figuring out,
"How do I set up
these GPU clusters?
How do I orchestrate this?
Is this synchronous?
Is it asynchronous?
Is it aggregated
or disaggregated?"
We manage that for you.
You focus on the algorithm, the
problem you're trying to solve,
and we manage the compute.
And with that, I'm going
to pass it off to Omkar
to show you what this
actually looks like.
Omkar More: Thank you.
So, in the previous
first two demos,
we looked at the high-level
APIs that Foundry provides.
These are great for
most of the cases
and for most of the people.
They are scenarios where you
just do fire and forget.
You give the tools,
you give the configuration,
you give the dataset,
and then let Foundry do its job.
But as I said, the more
effort you put in,
the more value you get.
So if you put in a little
bit more effort and want
to do it yourself,
we allow you to do
that with these low-level APIs,
wherein you write your own code,
and you can use these
smaller primitives
for doing forward pass, backward
pass, optim stage, sampling.
Things that are inherent that
require GPUs, leave that to us.
And you can write
your own recipes
that will give you
a lot more control.
So, in this demo, I'm going
to use our fine-tuning --
fine-grade APIs to fine-tune
OSS model Qwen3 32B
and see how it performs and
stacks with our scenario.
All right?
So let's get started.
But before that, just to
give you a visualization,
what does a recipe
really look like?
A recipe has specific
steps, like, "Hey,
first you're going
to take the dataset.
You're going to generate
multiple samples out of it."
So, essentially, let's say
one conversation request.
You could have 10 or
20 samples generated.
That's our different options
that the model is emitting out.
For that, you're going
to call our sample API,
which runs on GPUs where we have
preloaded a base LLM model,
and give you the responses.
You take these samples
and then go ahead
and write your own grader.
You can invoke your own grader
to see how these
samples were behaving.
And earlier, the
grader was supposed
to be limited to
what we support.
Let's say you want to
write a C-Sharp grader,
let's say you want to write
something completely different,
you can use that.
The tools, for instance, we
require you to update the tools
or upload the tools on an
MCP server or something.
Say you don't want to do that.
Say your tools are in some
format that are not compatible
with our high-level APIs.
You can use that now because you
have full control over invoking
of the tools in the
sampling process.
Alicia Frame: Or I could
even have interactions
with an environment.
So, execute the rollout,
call real tools
in the real world,
and see what happens.
Omkar More: Correct.
And then, once you do this,
this is the GRPO step
where you compute
the advantages,
like basically take the
mean of the samples and see
which ones are better.
And then, use the
forward-backward pass
to go ahead and
compute the gradients.
Behind the scenes,
we have two nodes.
One is called the training node,
and one is the sampling node.
And in the training node, we
run the forward-backward pass,
compute the gradients, and
then when you call sync,
we actually sync these
LoRAs to the sampling node.
And all of this requires
a lot of telemetry.
It's hard work that
you don't have to do
if you have to do it yourself.
Let's say you could very much
build it this way, but you have
to deal with nickel issues,
you would have to deal
with vLLM issues, as you said.
So we abstract all
of this out for you.
And once you're done, you can go
ahead and call sync checkpoint
and save the checkpoint
for training later on.
And the great
thing about this is,
this is not outside of Foundry.
All of this is within Foundry.
So you will see this
as a run on Foundry.
You can use the models as
any other model in Foundry.
You can use it with
hosted agents.
You can use it with evaluation.
The entire ecosystem is
right there for you.
So, with that, let me quickly
run this demo, and we'll see.
So, I have this as a --
So, in here, I have
a launcher script
that actually
launches the recipe,
and it starts a tmux session
that you can go
ahead and look at.
All of this is happening locally
on your own CPU machine.
You could run it on
your own laptop --
this is what I'm doing over here
-- or you could use an Azure VM
if you want to have
long-running sessions.
Now, when this is going
on, you can go ahead,
and we ship a small,
local dashboard.
This is because the training
entirely is happening
on your machines.
All the logs, fine-grained
logs, are there
on your machine itself,
and you can use
that to see how things
are performing.
So, with that, let me just open
up the local dashboard
that's running
and let me just
select an existing run.
Okay. So this is a completed
run with our low-level APIs.
You can see --
hopefully, it's visible.
You can see that the reward
and accuracy is increasing
over time, just like we
saw in the previous one.
But you also get
more details here.
So, for instance, you see that
the entropy is reducing down.
You'll see that the grand
norm is reducing down.
So all of this information
is much more fine-grained
that you get with this setup.
You will also see
the KL divergence.
You will see the group
composition becoming better
over time as well.
Alicia Frame: So I can
have a lot more control
over what I can even
see about this run.
So KL divergence is kind
of number one investigation
for reward hacking.
Couldn't see that before.
Now I can.
Omkar More: Yeah.
And this allows you to
have the full control
of all the telemetry
on your side.
You can tweak.
Say your recipe is ongoing,
and you mid-way decide that,
"Hey, I want to change this
to use a different
sampling strategy."
You can do that, and that's
where the interactive --
Alicia Frame: Or I could
use curriculum learning.
I can do whatever I want.
Omkar More: You can use
curriculum learning to start
with a very simple task
and then graduate it
to a larger and larger task.
You can do that, too.
Say you don't like GRPO,
you want to experiment
with some other mechanism, PPO
or DPO, and things like that,
you can change that, and you can
still use these same primitives
to tweak the way you want.
So, with that, let me get
back to the leaderboard
to see how this
stacks up with our --
-- runs.
This is my final
evaluation board.
You will see, hopefully, that
we have been able to beat,
even the o4-mini fine-tuned
version with Qwen3 32B.
So, much cheaper, smaller model,
and your agents are faster,
cheaper, and smarter.
Alicia Frame: Amazing.
Omkar More: Thank you.
Alicia Frame: And so, we've
now gone full, hard mode.
We went from simple UI
to, "Congratulations!
You are writing the training
algorithm yourself."
And so some of you who are not
data scientists might start
to feel a little anxious.
Me, I hear fine-tuning is great,
but this sounds really hard.
One common complaint we hear
is, "I don't even have the data
to train these models."
Or, something I hear a
lot is, "You know what?
I tried fine-tuning once.
I made the model worse.
I'm never doing this again."
And the good news
is we hear you,
and we've added a
fine-tuning skill.
So you can use your
favorite coding agent
and natural language to tell
it what you want to do,
and it's going to
figure that out.
And since I said
it's a PM skill,
I am going to do this demo.
And I actually don't trust
Claude and Copilot CLI
to do this on the fly,
and because I'm not running
a fine-tuned model,
it's a little slow.
So I ran this ahead of time.
But basically, you can see
what I did is I said, "Hey,
I've got a hosted agent here."
I gave it the address
of my hosted agent,
and I told it what
I wanted it to do.
This is Omkar's first demo.
I have an agent.
I want to figure out
how well it does.
So step one is I need
to make a grader.
I want it to grade to make sure
it's calling the right tools.
I want it to give
partial credit.
Please come up with that grader,
and then report how well
the model performs.
And I don't have to
learn the API, the SDK.
I don't have to click
around in that UI.
All it's going to do is
use the fine-tuning skill.
It knows how to build graders.
It knows how to call our APIs.
And great, it's done
the baseline for me.
It came up with the grader, so
it gives full credit if it asks
for clarification or if
it gets the answer right,
gives partial credit if it
gets some of the tool calls.
And then we go ahead, and
we grade the teacher model.
So this is our 5.4.
It's a little different because
this is a little different every
time I run it, but it gives
a mean score of 8.37,
pass rate at 8 of about 78%.
Teacher model is
doing pretty well.
Good. Okay.
Step two. I want to create
my fine-tuned model.
So I'm going to go ahead and
kick off a distillation run.
To do that, all I say is let's
I do say my goal is I want
it to be cheaper and faster,
and that's going to help it pick
which models to
fine-tune for me.
I want it to take my agent
traces from that agent I shared,
export them, filter
them, de-dup them,
and kick off a fine-tuning
autopilot run.
What that's going to do is it's
going to decide based on my data
and what I've described, which
models to run, which algorithm
to pick, and run a couple
different experiments
and see how it goes.
And so, what it's going to do
is I had it submit those jobs,
and in parallel, I wanted the
same kind of honesty check
that the base
models, the smaller,
cheaper base models are not
just great on their own.
So I ask it to do the same
thing we showed you earlier.
Let's evaluate the smaller,
cheaper base models,
and we'll see how we do.
And so, it ran, it
kicked off the baseline,
and I ran this before the
session, but you can see,
it got the base
model evals first.
Then, it finished training.
And just like before, we
have our leaderboard.
I had a winner.
I came up with a
fine-tuned 4.1 mini.
It picked mini and nano because
I said, "smaller and cheaper",
and it picked the
hyperparameters on its own.
And I can see that the
fine-tuned 4.1 mini gets almost
the same mean score, actually a
slightly higher pass at eight.
And so, I was able to do
that same distillation flow,
but with totally
natural language.
And this is part of the GitHub
Copilot for Azure skill,
or you can download a
separate fine-tuning skill
if you just want it
as a standalone.
And this really makes
fine-tuning accessible
and super easy.
So anyone can fine-tune.
And the cool thing
is, what it'll do is,
if these all actually just made
it worse, it'll look at the logs
and decide what it needs to
do next: generate more data,
try a different experiment, and
iterate until it gets it right.
And so, just to end, we
want a take-home message.
One thing we hear a lot --
we're going to dispel two myths.
The first is that, "I don't
need to fine-tune anymore
because frontier models
keep getting smarter.
Why would I need to fine-tune?"
And the real answer is, "Yes,
they're getting smarter,
but they're also getting bigger,
slower, and more expensive."
And you saw in the keynote
today, we can fine-tune small,
cheap models to outperform
frontier-class models.
And the advantage when
you fine-tune is your IP,
your business knowledge,
your domain, goes
into your custom model.
It's not going into that
frontier lab's weights for them
to make money off of you.
You keep your IP, you
get a smarter model
and better performance.
The other thing I want to touch
on is often people say, "Okay.
That was cool.
You showed me some cost savings.
It costs a lot to fine-tune.
You have to pay to train.
You have to pay to host.
I don't want to do this."
The real answer is, Omkar already
showed you developer tier
training, that's spot
capacity, 50% off.
The median supervised
fine-tuning job
on our platform costs
about a dollar.
It's not super expensive.
And we've introduced things
like developer tier hosting,
where there is no hosting fee.
So experimentation
is really easy.
It gives you the bridge to get
to production, and from there,
as your usage ramps up, you
see substantial cost savings.
And so, with that, we're
at the end of our talk.
We're going to take
questions afterwards,
feel free to come up to us.
But if you want to get started,
here are some resources.
The sample notebooks we showed
you today are in this repo.
You can sign up for the preview
of what Omkar showed you
with the training API,
or you can learn more.
And with that, we thank
you for your time.
And if you want to
see other sessions,
you can come to our lab.
We're running three
of them tomorrow.
You'll get to do hands-on with
the example we showed you
in the demo, learn how
to do reinforcement
learning yourselves.
And there are some other great
demos, breakout sessions,
and lightning talks that
you should check out.
So thank you so much.
[ Music ]